[Música]
hoy
los zapatos
y quiero empezar sin una pregunta
ustedes rápidamente algunos de ustedes
ha sentido que tiene una situación y que
ustedes sienten que no hay forma como en
situación que la única salida que
ustedes tienen es tirar la toalla
y tan llena de desesperación frustración
o qué sé yo miedo vergüenza
esto nos pasa mucho a cada quien nos
pasa nuestra vida pero yo quiero hablar
a ustedes de una historia que me gusta
muchísimo de un niño que de chiquito se
dio cuenta que era diferente a todos los
demás cuando tenía 6 años él sufrió una
mudanza del país se fue de república
americana estados unidos y perdió a lo
que conocía como sus juguetes sus amigos
la escuela
básicamente todo lo que un niño puede
verla
un año después sus padres se divorciaron
otra vez en nueve países entonces vuelve
a república americana entonces esta vez
no perdió todo sino que perdió todo y su
papá
su papá se queda en estados unidos pasó
de tener una familia nuclear a vivir
lejos de su padre
debido a todas estas situaciones
comienza a presentar un cuadro de estrés
y ansiedad muy grande para su edad y lo
que parecían ser tics
comenzaba a mover las manos y también se
le detectó una epilepsia nocturna
entonces tampoco podía dormir
esto es movimiento del que yo no hablo
con fueron incrementando con el estrés y
la ansiedad con la que él vivía
que se convirtió luego en bullying en el
colegio imagino que está muy bien
estos movimientos también impedían que
él escribía de clase y pedía que él
fuera a la iglesia sin parece un loco
no podía comer en los horarios
establecidos y como ya le había contado
no podía dormir pero ahora el dormía y
se movía durmiendo
poco después tiene que tener como nueve
años le diagnosticaron trastorno de
movimientos estereotípicos es una
afección en la que el individuo comienza
a hacer el movimiento repetitivo y sin
propósito del cuerpo entre los casos más
famosos tan mover las manos me hace el
cuerpo y el caso extremo golpearse la
cabeza
como ya dije estos movimientos
imposibilitan o por lo menos interfieren
con la actividad normal del día a día y
a raíz del diagnóstico entonces salieron
muchísimo más terapia conductual
acompañamiento medicina medicina
medicina medicina y la medicina
lamah y sola cosa eso que en gáldar
hizo que su mamá se quedara pobre
entonces se quedaron bajo el amparo de
los abuelos maternos por tres años
él su hermanita y forma en una
habitación de 33 años
qué pasa que en verdad a pesar de que
ellos habían tomado medida y demás nada
está mejorando y los medicamentos hacían
que no se sintiera como el mismo
entonces él se estresaba más y resulta
que ese trastorno se alimenta con el
estrés y la ansiedad entonces lo único
que estaba haciendo la que se moviera
más entonces no había forma
en el colegio cada vez la llama bullying
la nota no mejoraban él no escribía en
clase los cuernos llegaban vacío con
note en rojo de los profesores
como si no fuera suficiente los
especialistas vinieron a nuestra mamá y
le dijeron
mire señora él no va a poder seguir en
un colegio regular va a tener que ir a
un colegio para muchos especiales lo van
a tener que el médica toda su vida
y va a tener que andar con una sombra
una sombra de una persona que como un
gol de espalda que se asegura que tú no
te lastimes básicamente y se asegura de
que tú te comporte bien cómodo de tener
comporta bien en los intercambios
sociales verdad hicimos más le dijo
no gracias su mamá decidió que eso no
era lo que ella quería para su hijo y
agarro primero se guardó es un secreto
de que el diagnóstico agarró la medicina
la terapia los especialistas y las
apuestas con de la tiró para afuera
todavía dijo ok y apostó el 80% de su
tiempo en el que el 80 por ciento como
adultos que saben que muchísimo
qué pasa que una tarea de 20 minutos en
la cia en 5 horas entonces
el proceso de sí aunque algunos días
eran fáciles
la mayoría terminaba en desesperación
llanto dolor en los brazos porque que el
muchacho no entiende sin embargo su mamá
sigue apostando a él con todo su amor y
toda su fe
hoy día
ese niño vive una vida satisfactoria
plena saludable y feliz hoy día ese
muchacho no toman una pastilla no tiene
un gol de espalda y se graduó con
honores de un colegio normal que se
llama san judas tadeo hoy día ese niño
soy yo
y ustedes se preguntarán que hay como
340 la verdad eso es porque yo vine yo
vine a compartir con ustedes los pilares
de la vida que yo descubrí que me
ayudaron a conseguir el equilibrio
necesario para poder salir adelante y
quiero empezar con el evidente ya apoyo
incondicional de mi madre que día a día
se dedicó no hacerme la vida más fácil
sino a enseñarme cómo combatirla y
también me enseñó que ser diferente no
necesariamente era algo malo
ella una vez estaba en una reunión de
profesorado cuando en mi momento de
crisis más grande y los profesores le
dijeron mira él va a tener que retirar
el colegio que se está quemando él no
tiene clase para mí sabiendo que lo que
pasaba de verdad y siendo ella profesora
y coach toda la cosa ya vino mínimo
vamos ahora pues la próxima clase
ustedes van a donde mi hijo le van a
preguntar todo lo que usted anda deny
entero si él no responde pongan un cero
que yo lo saqué si él responde todo
ustedes van a tener que evaluarlo como
él puede ser evaluado y para ser el
cuento algo corto yo pasa a cuadro de
honor incluso protagonizó una obra
teatral que christmas carol de office
clutch y me tiré 18 páginas de guión así
con 9 años normal
luego esta educación de calidad para
seguir la historia a pesar de que a mí
me fue muy bien ese colegio del cual
final
el bullying no en mis cursos sino un
curso de arriba sigue igualito entonces
yo lo que hice fue que me fui de ahí
hablamos y me cambié a él san judas
tadeo genial en ese colegio
la diferencia no es que no es tanto la
calidad escolar sino la perspectiva
porque ya yo fue este colegio y mami fue
con un contrato para que los profesores
dirección estuviera consciente de lo que
yo tenía y de que en caso de que vengan
a admitir tenían que evaluar me en base
a lo que yo podía hacer
y bueno aunque no lo voy a decir que
desde el inicio fue un palo de
estudiante pero poco a poco yo fui
progresando y terminé grabando menores
no me vaya todo muy bien
número 3 está el acceso a materias
optativas como así música ajedrez
natación estas cosas me ayuda a mí a
controlar la ansiedad que yo le dije
usted de que era gasolina por el
trastorno que yo tengo porque no se cura
entonces yo aprendí a controlar mis
manos mi mente mi cuerpo y poco a poco
nos fuimos dando cuenta yo toco trompeta
estoy usando la mano por tanto no estoy
moviéndome yota con natación utilizó
todos los músicos de mi cuerpo
yo tenía ajedrez mi mente está aprende a
enfocarse entonces ya con estas
actividades aprendimos que la medicina
que necesitaba no era un fármaco que iba
mal y te comprabas y no esas clases que
verdaderamente me llamaban y que también
crearon pasiones en mi ahí dando forma
lo que yo soy hoy día número 4 está
rodearme de personas adecuadas mis
mejores amigos son personas
excepcionales seis agentes son el final
de los finales mis amigos en el colegio
se la comieron todito yo digo que yo me
gradué como nombre pero esa gente
sagrado como honoré honor e honorífico
allá arriba en un amigo que está aquí
sentados acá 98 de promedio una leyenda
esa gente básicamente yo verlos a ellos
que ese yo cada quien tiene su situación
diferente sin embargo ya estaban ahí me
motivaba a mí a día a día hacer una
mejor versión de mí que yo miraba para
atrás y yo decía yo soy mejor que eso
que yo dejé atrás
número 5 y no menos importante es mi
relación con dios yo tengo muchos
ejemplos de cómo dios me ayudaba en mi
vida pero quiero hablar de uno ya
postcrisis que fue recientemente y dijo
recientemente así como un año 2
yo solía participar en el grupo de
acción santísima trinidad y allá una
hermana llamado juniors me dijo un día
llegó acá
yo tengo que decirte yo dígame juniors
que tiene un don para identificar al
agente diego usted es salmón no camarón
de una vaca como así como los profesores
te lo dejo de tarea va carísimo entonces
puedes imaginar yo fui a mi casa de una
vez google me llamaron
animal marino salmón
lo mismo entonces yo estaba como que de
bueno pero no encontrando nada y
supuestamente sin sermón dice juniors yo
sé que yo él sabe ok
un mes después me lo encuentro en la
iglesia juniors
falle la tarea pero yo necesito que tú
media promete un gobierno pues a ver
dijo como así pero si tú inventiva el
camarón dice que como se duerme se lo
lleva la corriente si tú sabes del salmo
tú sabes que el salmón cuando va a dar a
los huevitos el sube contra el río
verdad para dejar en las aguas
cristalinas los huevitos porque nada tan
bien entonces vaya lo que tuvo de cierto
tú era el animal y la corriente de la
sociedad mucha gente son camarón
avisaron por ahí como no lo que usted
como usted sabe lo que usted quiere
usted no le importa y usted sube en
contra la sociedad y le llega a los
niveles
yo dije oye unión nutre ella
cuando él me dijo eso básicamente
después de que júnior me dijo que se
convirtió como un moto y yo he dado
mucha charla basado en eso que yo no me
dijo que se llamaba nadar
contracorriente bueno para seguir
historia verdad he compartido con
ustedes los cinco pilares pero además de
eso yo quiero contarle que yo
identifiqué que en mi vida había un
factor que si yo no hubiera desarrollado
yo nunca hubiera llegado yo no voy atado
aquí como está ahora mismo yo tuviera un
manicomio del qué sé yo y se llama
resiliencia
la resiliencia es una capacidad muy rara
por ese masoquista porque básicamente
toda garra el dolor ese que te estás
sintiendo que te apuñalan dow en una
situación y tú lo hagas rytas amigos de
ese dolor y tú aprendes o dolor dolor
dime cómo vas a hacer entonces todo
aprende del dolor y para cuando tengas
otra situación entonces tenemos
preparado la capacidad para adaptarse y
como sabemos de darwin el que se adapta
el que sobrevive
entonces yo aprendí esta resiliencia
gracias al transcurso que yo tuve en mi
vida de youtube y feliz todo pero no fue
fácil sin embargo aunque no fue fácil yo
cierro mis ojos hoy ahora y miro hacia
atrás y yo lo que veo es triunfo y
victoria porque a pesar de todo eso
medicina y todas esas cosas que me
hicieron sentir fatal todo eso fue
necesario para generar el producto que
está aquí hablando de ustedes hoy o sea
si yo no hubiera pasado todo eso mi
charla ahora mismo no tuviera ningún
propósito
qué pasa quiero antes de concluir
contarles dos momentos de vida que
también marcaron mucho mi personalidad
de hoy el primero fue otra vez con mi
madre yo estaba en el baño llorando
tenía que tener entre 11 y 12 años
estaba en esos momentos de crisis yo
contaba y no me encuentran en el baño
diego vera castro de paz y yo mami no
que me están diciendo que yo soy
diferente y me comienza el rey y yo
se volvió loca
tu tabla de mí ahora también como a mí
no me dijo mira si a ti te dicen
diferente significa que si no mi trabajo
bien como madre porque ya no creo en
fotocopias
oye ya llegué al colegio y ya no había
forma
la forma lo que era mi debilidad se
convirtió en mi armadura o sea mi
personalidad díaz se basa en que hace
diferente y que a mí no me importa nada
y quieta vaya atrás yo tenía aquí al
baño y llegué que hacemos quitando por
el estrés pero estamos bien estamos aquí
y verdad entonces el otro momento
gracias gracias
el otro momento un poco mi papá y fue un
poco más reciente él me llamo eeuu yo
sigo bien en europa porque él
desapareció
mi papá me llamó y me dijo que decir que
se ha quitado mucha participación
x circunstancia pero yo creo que sucede
para que desde muy chiquito yo me di
cuenta que yo tenía
primero mucha creatividad y mucha
inteligencia que tuve un tipo duro y yo
sé que soy un tipo duro porque ahora
mismo lo que pasa no importa
la buena es rara que tú tengo porque yo
solo que yo no creo en eso que tú tienes
pero nada de eso opaca para mí que si tu
padre la grandeza a la que tú fuiste
llamado oye ya básicamente yo dije no
probamos cambiada charla decir que no
tengo nada claro yo fui un poco más
pero ese ese esa perspectiva lo que me
hizo aprender fue que la persona no
damos no queremos como que mata a
nosotros mismos nosotros vemos todo lo
negativo que tenemos no que si el pelo
que sí etc lo otro y no nos damos cuenta
que cada quien tenemos cosas
maravillosas que compartir o sea ustedes
van a ver ahora en la charla del té de
podido conocerse a gente maravillosa
gente que si tú la conoce en el día a
día se ven muy normales y que se puede
tener mucho problema pero cuando usted
escuche usted vecinos el ejemplo son
genio pero no son genio
porque si no vamos a eso entonces todos
somos genios como dice albert einstein
qué pasa
la resiliencia que yo estaba contando yo
quiero que ustedes cuando usted esté en
un momento de dolor en su vida de
adversidad que usted el agarre así la
abrazo
y se recuerde el toque le puede decir
que dijo henry ford
cuando todo esté en contra de ti
recuerda que el avión despega contra el
viento y no a favor de él muchas gracias